comment il va lambert quant à l'or il
est content là de l'arrivée de ce petit
ce petit joyau de la couronne il dira ce
petit d'enfants ac est arrivé alors on
l'on est content de lui
le choix du roi après un petit garçon
s'en souvient archibal harrison en 2019
une petite fille le choix du roi le
choix de la reine en quelques sortes il
me faudrait dire donc c'était c'est la
reine tel choisi le prénom de lille i
bet diana non là bas avant la reine n'a
pas du tout le choix du roi ces on-dit
l'effet miroir comme un garçon et un
milieu
alors j'ai pas bien compris qu à petit
le bail c'est le roi qui a choisi un
ballon dégagé marib a sélectionné
l'autre question
[Rires]
la reine et la famille royale ont
félicité arrimer ghana ce que ça veut
dire ça va mieux entre eux ou c'est
juste des apparences c'est une bonne
question
en tout cas ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que à nouveau cher qu'une mégane rien ne
se passe comme dans la tradition comme
ceux qui ne devrait menacer dans la
balance et buckingham palace qui prend
les choses en main et qui annonce
officiellement l'arrivée de l'enfant
tout cela est une présentation à la
presse et par une photo epa ici on a su
la naissance de leur de lille i bet et
diana
dimanche alors qu'elle est née le
vendredi soir oui si c'est absolument à
nous faut rien ne se fait comme ça se
passe ces trois jours après et c'est
surtout les américains qui se sont
entichés de cette naissance puisque la
cbs la chaîne américaine où collaborent
oprah winfrey a carrément interrompu ses
programmes pour annoncer l'événement
alors que les anglais si on prend la
peine de regarder un peu les titres de
la presse car de 8 ce matin il n'y a que
des sun et le daily telegraph qui
consacrent leur une à l'événement
les autres se contentent de manchette
nicolas est ce que vous pensez que la
reine était au courant de ce long ou pas
du tout vous avez été fait dans son dos
prix et non quelle base ils n'ont
apparemment elle ne serait pas au
courant de ce que l'on peut dire par
rapport à ce prénom beaucoup focalise
sur diana c'est pas tellement diana qui
fait vraiment grincer des dents sanibel
pourquoi parce que lily bête était le
petit surnom de la reine s'est donné
elle-même lorsqu'elle avait 2 ans sont
receptor donné un surnom disent les
anglais elle tentait de de prononcer son
prénom elissa met c'est un peu compliqué
mais l'a dit lily bête et ce surnom est
resté mais il n'a été autorisée qu'à
trois personnes trois seules personnes
ont pu l'utiliser à savoir ça sort la
défunte princesse margaret qui était
sublime subi sa mère queen même et son
mari qu'elle vient de perdre le prince
philip
il serait donc possible de se dire que
si la reine n'avait pas perdu son mari
il ya quelques mois et que le prénom
aurait encore été visités
probablement car les médias n'auraient
pas opérer ce choix
royal ils ont chacun un petit à petit
nickname en petits surnoms et que celui
ci en hommage en quelque sorte qu harry
a vu peut-être rendre ces gentils oui
c'est tout mignon c'est mignon pour une
fois je je suis pas contrarier mégane
pour une france libre et franchement
niebel projetant ça pas mal c'est mignon
et attrape les lignes ah ouais vas
tellement ils sont issus très bas parce
que l'idée est certes impossible de
parier sur l'île ça rigole et ça paie
genre ouais on va mettre et on va mettre
un billet sur mon avis je lis ça et
personne n'avait parié sur l'ibex qui
veut dire que celui qui gagne le awalé
paris bien sûr la page au nom de terre
et paris sur les prénoms et voir des
contorsions délais mais sur notre terre
ils parleraient même sur les
chroniqueurs qui sont langouët laménie
c'est très mignon lilibet c'est très
mignon ghana c'est très mignon mais
malgré tout voudrais pas que c'est une
provocation
à vous d'en démonter la royauté ils ont
démonté beckingham en disant qu'ils
étaient racistes qu'ils avaient été plus
normal traitant avec un pardon mais là
là réellement
voilà une sorte de slogan on veut bien
faire on veut cela vient un peu notre
conscience alors on va mettre un petit
peu diverses arènes un petit peu de
ghana pour la mémoire
c'est ce que la presse tabloïde est en
train de dire aujourd'hui et ils tirent
encore hommes sur le couple sur le sexe
et alors on reprend peut-être cette
formule qui a été visité par le times le
times titre en manchette welcome lily
bêtes afin welcome lisbet we welcome
ligny bête
[Rires]
en train de devenir les suspects mais
c'est comme cela qu'ils ne s'installent
ici sont un peu en train de devenir en
truck d'hériter d'une famille royale
américano voilà il y avait les kennedy
il y aura peut-être un jour laissé c'est
que c'est sous cette espère quentin sur
wii gilles verdez ailleurs le l'enfant a
la double nationalité anglaise et
américaine
bien sûr chacune ans pour l'instant il à
la nation face une démarche pour qu'il
obtienne la nationalité britannique
qu'il va obtenir automatiquement puisque
son père et brittany voilà oui sky et
même un canard américain qui a dit que
plus tard elle pourrait éventuellement
une présidente des états unis
officiellement 6 1 6 1
sous nos trains soit président est pour
l'instant le mien il a quatre en
géographie avec toujours été très engagé
meghan markle vous le savez et même le
choix de l'hôpital ici le santa barbara
hospital dont vous n'avez pas fini et
anchois et anchois engagée qu'elle a
fait puisqu'on sait que cet hôpital en
1891 a été créée par 50 femmes qui ont
été vraiment pour le féminisme on attend
qu'ils ont choisi de vous et wind tu
étais vraiment ta femme accouche tu vas
le projet aurait dû choisir normalement
le cedars sinaï hospital qui est présent
l'hôpital des stars qu'est l'hôpital où
beyoncé a accouché à une nouvelle star
c'est barras et le césar s'il s'est
prudemment le cedar faut trouver pack
encore une fois ray et mégane envie de
faire de la provocation de faire parler
d'eux sur le dos de leurs enfants
avec la double nationalité l'annoncé
prénom avec ces gens là nous avions
l'année sans même les fracas street
marketing
si on la laissait quand même un peu
peut-être en tirer bénéfice du tout le
bénéfice du doute
voilà libye bête en tout cas c'est très
joli espérons que ça puisse peut-être
tenté d'apaiser les choses et le 1er
juillet harry est de retour à londres
il sera seul telle règle avait le ventre
[Rires]
pour le premier fils et diana aurait eu
60 ans déjà inauguré une statue
apparemment et j'adresse à louis
non je me braque 3 très bien on va le
priver quand même si quand même pas où
il brigue cela dit l'hôpital santa
barbara ce à côté de chez eux
oui oui à kris km 15 km oui los angeles
est beaucoup plus loin ah ouais ah oui
c'est au moins 80 bornes moi tu sais toi
avec accouché connard silberthal cas ce
qui porte à quelque chose à ajouter
non je peux dire c'est que cet ex usm 5
ms bon choix le capital et politique
pour meghan markle je puisse réellement
vous avez raison que je crois qu'elle
ment on va la retrouver en politique
mais danemark il est né le 4 juin à
11h40
il pesait 3 kg 5 à la naissance 403 qui
le 480 g ha à la naissance il pesait 35